[Música]
bienvenidos a este especial de deportes
en france 24 la pandemia de kobe 19
marcó al 2020 y el deporte no fue la
excepción por el coronavirus los juegos
olímpicos fueron aplazados un año un
hecho sin precedentes en la historia de
la competencia aunque la organización ya
mira hacia 2021 aún quedan muchas
incógnitas sobre cómo se celebrará el
evento multidisciplinar el próximo año
en acceso o no a la vacuna a la
presencia de público y en qué cantidad
los protocolos a respetar por los
atletas y el desarrollo de los torneos
clasificatorios faltantes son sólo
algunos de los aspectos a resolver en
este informe repasamos los desafíos para
toque 2020 + 1
el cob y 19 causó algo inédito en la
historia del olimpismo la cita deportiva
por excelencia debió postergarse un año
seif para salvaguardar la salud de los
atletas y todos los involucrados en los
juegos olímpicos de 10 de olympic games
to postpone tenemos que posponer los
juegos olímpicos y paralímpicos tokio
2020 al año 2021
wang una situación que plantea múltiples
desafíos para la organización y está
sujeta a la evolución de la pandemia
aunque a mitad de 2020 se consideró la
idea de unos juegos a escala reducida
los avances de la vacuna alimentan la
ilusión de un evento con público
el mejor escenario por supuesto sería
que todos los atletas de todos los
países vinieran aquí con seguridad y
tranquilidad y los juegos olímpicos
pudieran como en años anteriores
celebrarse con la presencia de la
totalidad de espectadores hoy ponemos de
cnooc a thaci dear indagará
pero los interrogantes aún son muchos y
el comité olímpico internacional que
evalúa escenarios diversos
una campaña de vacunación a gran escala
hasta un panorama sin la inmunización
disponible en forma masiva una pequeña
muestra de como podrían ser los juegos
de 2.021 el torneo internacional de
gimnasia artística disputado en
noviembre que contó con protocolos
estrictos y separó a las delegaciones de
cada país en burbujas sanitarias
nos avisaron que antes del desayuno nos
hacemos una prueba de covite y que
estaría bien durante el día también nos
dieron celulares que nos alertan si
alguien tiene covite en el grupo están
siendo muy seguros y cautelosos pero no
es como si estuviéramos en prisión
creo que la competición en la que
participamos demuestra que los juegos
olímpicos pueden y deben celebrarse
pruebas frecuentes restricciones de
movimiento y saneamiento social siempre
que fuera posible y otras medidas están
siendo contempladas por los
organizadores que se preparan para los
que sean posiblemente los juegos
olímpicos más particulares de la
historia
los protagonistas de los juegos
olímpicos son los atletas y para ellos
el coach 19 ha significado una bruta
interrupción en la preparación para el
evento con consecuencias de todo tipo
para hablar sobre el tema nos
comunicamos con antonio díaz karateca
venezolano que competirán los juegos
olímpicos son los primeros y últimos
para su disciplina gracias a antonio por
estar en france 24 y como han impactado
las restricciones por la pandemia en su
preparación para los juegos
en mi caso creo que el punto más
importante fue pues psicológico o mental
sobre todo la preocupación de no saber
qué iba a pasar por los juegos al
principio
un poco también el no tener ese enfoque
o constante de competencias pero
analizándolo después creo que he tratado
de aprovechar ese tiempo extra que
tenemos con la postergación de los
juegos para buscar una mejor
planificación para la preparación para
llegar mejor en condiciones físicas
la preparación que va a tener que hacer
después de terminar los campeonatos
clasificatorios para los juegos
olímpicos iba a ser muy corta
y tenía que ser muy rápida ahora con un
poco más de tiempo a pesar de las
restricciones y de las condiciones que
hemos tenido que adaptarnos por por la
confinamiento citó y me ha permitido
planificar y preparar pensar que puedo
llegar un poco mejor en cuanto a las
condiciones físicas para esta cita
olímpica
como todas las personas del mundo los
atletas están expuestos a un posible
contagio de coronavirus marian arceo
pentatleta mexicana fue uno de esos
casos y nos contó cómo le afectó haber
contraído la enfermedad bueno pues sí
fue una situación difícil a la cual el
frente porque fue de los inicios o sea
de mi país todavía no se conocía mucho
se escuchaban los rumores por por este
francia e italia y todo eso pero yo
estaba en barcelona cuando yo me
contagié
la verdad es que pues no medio le veo si
yo sé que muchas personas a ellas
automáticas la verdad que padre que son
dudas pero en mi caso pues sí para decir
creo que el virus el como la fuerte el
virus fuerte no el cual pues sí me trajo
una neumonía la cual me mantuvo pues en
el hospital durante un mes desde el
ingreso que tuve al hospital ya lo podía
estar de pie y está preparando de justo
para juegos olímpicos ya no iba a
regresar a mi país no pretendíamos
regresar entonces fue que me dio es no
dure con la neumonía aproximadamente un
mes otro mes de recuperación y bueno fue
largo fueron tres meses así en que pues
tuve que ver mucho por mi salud
afortunadamente ya me encuentro bien
tuve una disciplina en cuanto a la
recuperación de mis pulmones y todo y no
tengo secuelas estoy ahorita entrenando
y la verdad es que mis tiempos están
mejorando también esto será la
dedicación que ha tenido últimamente
pero pues contenta de tener la nueva
oportunidad de poder disfrutar de mí
pues a la mente
el temor al contagio los confinamientos
la incertidumbre que rodeó y aún rodea a
los juegos olímpicos
antonio cómo manejar la cabeza frente a
todas estas variables más en su caso con
un deporte como el karate que requiere
tanto fortaleza física como mental
por supuesto que manejarse en este
concepto es difícil cuando a veces no
sabes otras la incertidumbre de cómo va
a estar la situación
algunos meses cuando es que bueno si hay
noticias positivas en cuanto a las
vacunas y todo pero también tienes ves
como los casos también suben hay un
segundo confinamientos en europa
entonces todo eso te va generando un
poco de estrés un poco de incertidumbre
y yo creo que en mi caso la mejor manera
de afrontarlo ha sido enfocándome en mi
trabajo ha sido cuando me de preparación
en disfrutar de lo que tengo al momento
pues también esa posibilidad que me ha
dado esta cuarentena o ésta
no posibilidad de viajar para compartir
con mi familia para disfrutar de mí de
mi hijo de mi esposa eso creo que ha
sido algo en lo que tenía he tratado de
enfocarme para para trabajar pues esa
esa fortaleza mental y aprovechar el
tiempo aprovechar el día a día sigue sin
tener una expectativa
sin crearse una expectativa de que las
cosas van a estar bien mañana o pasado
mañana sino bueno trabajar trabajar y
esperar que el momento llegue por
supuesto que con la meta fija de hacer
una mejor representación o hacer el
mejor papel en los juegos olímpicos pero
por supuesto concentrados en el día a
día y no proyectar a futuro
el deporte tampoco ha quedado exento del
impacto económico que provocó el hobbit
19 y para los atletas olímpicos muchos
de origen amateur la falta de
competencia y de ayuda se los llevó a
buscar ingresos de diversas formas
daniel branne bell campeón británico en
salto en largo pasó tres meses durante
el verano europeo trabajando como
repartidor de amazon una tarea exigente
que le costó combinar con el
entrenamiento tras finalizarse de su
historia en las redes sociales la
campaña de recaudación de fondos que
había lanzado en 2019 se disparó y
alcanzó el objetivo que se había
planteado casos similares también
vivieron dos esgrimistas que son
medallistas que fueron medallistas
olímpicos en londres 2012 y que se
convirtieron en repartidores de comida a
domicilio por un lado el japonés el río
miyake que dijo haber optado por esta
actividad para ahorrar dinero y
mantenerse en forma y por el otro
también el venezolano rubén limardo que
comenzó a trabajar en polonia para
sobrevivir mientras sueña con ser el
primer esgrimista en ganar dos medallas
olímpicas en competencias individuales
esto fue lo que dijo limardo sobre su
situación
pandemia animales de boda por la
pandemia no hay competencia algunos
patrocinadores dicen que nos volverán a
pagar después del año nuevo y también
estará crisis de nuestro país entonces
tenemos que ganar dinero en la sky o
asia y noche de bacheo azúcar fillón
sana o lisa antonio veíamos la situación
de su compatriota limardo también de
bram ver pueden profundizarse los
desequilibrios entre los atletas que
durante la pandemia tuvieron los
recursos para mantener su preparación y
aquellos que debieron salir a trabajar
una situación que también marca
diferencias por ejemplo entre europeos y
latinoamericanos
yo creo que qué
lo he pensado he visto compañeros que en
las elecciones europeas que viven y
entrenan en centros de alto rendimiento
son condiciones que generalmente no
vemos desde ese tipo de concentraciones
en nuestros países
y a veces uno puede pensar pues que eso
puede ser un poco una ventaja pero creo
que
en la posibilidad de buscar condiciones
y sobreponerse a estos momentos
difíciles también te fortalece
mentalmente y te fortalece ese espíritu
no yo creo que qué
al final si logramos conseguir las
condiciones por supuesto para
prepararlos técnica y físicamente que
son importantes esas dificultades que
estamos pasando también pueden ser una
ganancia no entonces ver desde ese punto
de vista ver como tal vez hacer más
fuertes a esta situación y sobreponernos
nos va a dar también una ventaja
nosotros mental
pero pese a todo un juego olímpico es un
juego olímpico el sueño de todo
deportista en su caso antonio también
marcará su retiro como profesional como
imagina la competencia y qué
expectativas tiene bueno mi idea siempre
ha sido disfrutarla muchísimo siempre he
visto ese escenario como un regalo una
oportunidad de culminar mi carrera
en el evento deportivo más importante y
además en un lugar emblemático para
nosotros por lo que representa japón
para la disciplina del karate entonces
creo que que no no si hubiese tenido que
escoger un lugar y un evento no no
hubiese podido ser mejor no entonces por
eso quiero disfrutarlo al máximo
vamos a ver también me gustaría que
exista la posibilidad de que de que los
juegos se den
con público y que puedan viajar personas
que me gustaría que estuvieran ahí
disfrutando de ese último competencia
como son mis padres y como como mi
esposa
mi hijo me encantaría poder tenerlos ahí
en ese momento pero pero
independientemente de que se puede o no
por las razones de d
de las pandemias
va a ser un momento increíble en mi
carrera deportiva y voy a tratar de
aprovechar cada segundo para disfrutarlo
al máximo
muchas gracias antonio y a todos ustedes
por acompañarnos en este especial rumbo
a tokio 2020 1 sigan con más información
en france 24 y france 24 puntocom
a
[Música]